the girag and experience are you get 16
hours to read my audiobook I was like oh
my god you know I cannot read out loud
to save my life
16 hours how many hours is the actual
audio book 3 whoa that's crazy I am the
worst outloud reader and for like the
first day today getting mad if you fuck
it up
yeah the guy who asked me like on the
first first chapter he's like hey man do
you need glasses
just I was like no I just know I'm not
that good but and I was like I'll do it
drunk everyone wants to hear me do a
drunk you can't fucking read drunk so
then I described that - that day's all
useless way to go back and redo it and
then and then I was also like like I'd
read a passage and then I go on and be
like like and then I'd expound on what I
just read and kind of a second I was
like a podcast and that was fucking
horrible that took like forever and so
that finally the guys like just fucking
read it so I just read it towards the
end but it gets better
I would I would think it would be better
if you just read it and if you fucked up
just comment on the fact that you fucked
that word up and just keep going on like
that way people would they get they get
the book the whole book but they'd also
get the experience of you reading the
book like you separating yourself from
the book while you read it oh yeah I
mean oh they III don't know what it's
gonna sound like but because I did
acknowledge it I did when I did fuck out
cuz I'm a comic so I would work the
piece as I was like if I was on stage
okay so did they keep that in or do they
edit that stuff they kept I think they
kept some of it in but they couldn't
kept all of it in
that's so weird though they decide what
gets left in and what comes out this
whole through this whole book writing
process has been vulnerable as fuck
because you you really let go of it
because it's an entirely different
industry yeah I didn't I passed I had a
book deal I was writing the book and
they were still giving these wacky
fucking notes just advice on like how I
should talk about things what I should
describe how it I was like we're not
this is not happening
you know you're not involved in the
creative process yeah no I gave them
their money back I was like this is
crazy like they wanted me to essentially
write my act down on paper and sell it
as a book they're like well George
Carlin did it and Jerry Seinfeld did it
I was like that's nice I don't give a
f--- I'm not doing that
oh yeah that's right different than I do
stand up it's two different things like
you can write when you're writing like
just writing there's a way that you can
express yourself that's unavailable if
you're talking right you know it's it's
y-you Dragon Dictate didn't work for me
because you talked it into this Dragon
Dictate and it will put it right into
the computer yeah like print it but it
didn't work for me because it sounded
spoken like it sounded like and a couple
like and one of the hard things for me
was I did that same thing where they
wanted all the stories I had told on
stage or on podcast I was like I can't
do that I can't just fill it up with
that yeah they want the stuff that they
think they're gonna sell it's not a
artistic thing it's like guess what
dummy the same person that told those
funny stories I can tell you other funny
stories like we're not running out of
funny stories here it's really
fascinating and like their stories I had
to put in the book I had to put the
machine in I can't not write that in
there and there's a lot of there's a
click the Will Smith story I had to put
it in then I wanted to do the several
poles one I wanted to do one where I met
Ralph Sampson and when I was a kid I was
Ralph Sampson um he was a basketball
player and I was I went to school it I
went to I was like in eighth grade I
decided I really want to be a basketball
player and so I went to Villanova
basketball camp and Ralph Sampson came
to speak and like the first night I got
a concussion and the two best basketball
players got pulled out for drinking so
the next day I had to sit out with to
that spot ball players and everyone
thought we drank together so now all of
a sudden I'm 15 14 and everyone thinks
I'm cool I'm parting with the 18 year
olds so Ralph Sampson comes I thought
this defined me Ralph Sampson comes up
to give a speech he's like I'm here to
talk to you about two things there's
5,000 kids on the gym floor
he said we're talking about basketball
and we're talking about discipline first
let's talk about discipline who in here
parties and I was on the impression we
were all gonna put our hands up but I
was the only fucking person
I just went chunk and he was like oh one
person 5,000 kids no one raised her
fucking hand he's like how do you party
I was fucking 13 I know how to I didn't
I've never partied in my life so all I
said was Hardy and he fucking lost it
and 5,000 kids are slapping the gym
floor like oh shit we're gonna make an
example out of you party animal he's
lost the room so he brings me up front
to the in front of all the kids and he
makes me stand up
and he puts a basketball behind my legs
like this and then one on my arms like
this and he's like we party hearty we're
gonna party hearty today so I'm standing
like this for his whole fucking hour
speech with a basketball here and there
and he's like he keeps coming back to me
and by the way I'm so in my head that I
have social anxiety disorder but I'm in
front of everyone and I'm like being
made fun I'm being mocked that I wasn't
listening to his questions to me is like
you think you'll ever party again I just
said yeah and the fucking place went
bananas they're like oh and he's like
how do you party Harty I was like and I
didn't know the answer I just was like
with two hands fucking people are losing
you think you do marijuana and now I'm
killing I'm like I'll get two in college
and these kids
I left that gym and everyone wanted to
talk to me everyone's like party animal
what are you doing and that you're still
holding the basketball between your legs
yeah the whole fucking time so why
you're cracking jokes while I'm cracking
jokes come on did you hold the
basketball an hour that's a long time my
cousin Ava almost brought him here today
I should have I didn't even think about
it my cousin Abe was there at the camp
he because he's from Philly I didn't
know anyone because names like I think I
didn't know you party like oh I don't I
don't I just thought we don't put our
fucking hands ha ha he's like you know
why would you put your hands up if you
don't party I was like I wanted to be
cool ah so yeah so like so now and then
everyone would come up and they'd be
like party animal you partying Hardy
tonight I'd be like yeah but then I
became cool at that camp and then I have
friends and so I wrote that story's a
little longer and I gave it to them I go
this is the best story this defines me I
don't like uh I'm not really that's
hilarious
so it's all partying stories but it's
like that's a hilarious story no thanks
that's so nutty that this could have
possibly sent you on a path when you
were that young yeah you know 13 years
old I just I and it's all just wanting
to be accepted did you ever have one of
those moments where you'd go somewhere
and you didn't know anybody sure you
felt like everyone fucking grew up
together yeah that's a weird feeling I
felt like that a lot as a kid yeah but I
thought that that defined me cuz then I
became the part I became the party
animal that kind of lived up to whatever
I by the way I went to high school the
very next year didn't know anyone so I'm
sure that kind of I was like well it
worked in Villanova so yeah there's
definitely
different personality that develops when
kids have to move to write if they move
from one spot to another spot they moved
more than once that yeah developed it's
like it's just weird newcomer
personality you know in every romantic
kids movie the rebel that moved into
town the new kid that you don't know if
anything he smokes cigarettes and
fucking Twilight style movie or even
like Karate Kid didn't he like move into
some new town dude cry kid
I fucking the day Karate Kid came out
was my first day at tennis camp and so
so I go I gotta fucking can't believe I
didn't write about this this fuck
I didn't mean know anyone I know anyone
so then the these all the libary on the
camp I started meeting the cool kids and
they're like hey man what are you doing
today I was like nothing and they like
you wanna go see Karate Kid and I didn't
know anything about it I was like oh
yeah I'll be cool
so like cool meet us at Mission Bell
that's where this place was my mom's
late picking me up we're late doing
everything she drops me off to the movie
late and I go in and the movies already
started I can't find any of the kids but
I already bought the ticket and I
already have popcorn in a drink
and I'm like fuck so I just go down and
I sit down I've never seen a movie by
myself at that time and I just sit down
and I keep looking for him but I can't
fucking find him but then the movie
starts and it's a great fucking movie
and it's a movie about a loner kid like
myself that doesn't know anyone and he's
trying to break into the new group just
like I was doing a tennis camp and I
really get involved in it I get so
involved in the movie that when he does
the fucking crane kick and kicks the guy
I start bawling fucking crying thinking
I'm Daniel son I'm Dan in my head I'm
like I feel like Daniel son the house
lights come up and the fucking kids that
were had wanted me to meet were sitting
directly like two rows in front of me
and I heard you weeping they heard me
crying and I'm sorry weeping like
lobbing like a fucking ten-year-old cry
like if you were ten how'd that work out
uh they turned around and they saw me
crying and they were about to make fun
of me and they're like oh you got us you
got we thought you were crying you
fucking with us you were sitting on us
the whole time and I was like yeah yeah
that's it that's it I fucking walked out
that movie I still of this day so you
you had a fake that you weren't quite a
fake that I wasn't crying and then we
all hung out there like you just do that
make yourself cry I was like